على الرغم من بذل قصارى جهدك لتخزين
المنتجات بشكل صحيح ، يمكن أن تبدو بعض الأطعمة
وكأنها جاهزة للنفايات قبل
أن تعرفها وأنت لست وحدك من
عام 1961 إلى 2011 ، فقد تضاعف فقدان الطعام وهدره ثلاث مرات على
مستوى العالم ، فهذه أخبار سيئة
للبيئة مثل فقد الطعام  وإهدار
مساهمين مهمين في انبعاثات
غازات الاحتباس الحراري ،
ولكن ماذا لو بمساعدة العلم ،
يمكنك تنفيذ معجزات المطبخ التي تجلب
المنتجات التي تجاوزت أفضل حالاتها
إذا كان كل ما لديك في
ثلاجتك يبدو وكأنه
ذابل قد فقد القليل من الرطوبة حيث
طالما أنه ليس طريًا إذا كان طريًا ،
فمن المحتمل أنك لا ترغب في تناوله ،
فما أحب أن أفعله هو أنني عادة ما أقوم بتبييض
الكثير من الخضار ثم أضعها في
الماء المثلج ، وعادة لا أسلق
لأكثر من  دقيقة ، لذا فإن السلق لن يقوم
فقط بطهيها قليلاً ،
ولكنه أيضًا يقتل أي بكتيريا قد
تكون متبقية منذ أن تضع في
الماء المغلي وتضعه في
ماء بارد مما سيساعد في الحفاظ على النوع.
من سلامة الخضار التي تقوم
بسلقها أو يمكنك تركها في
الماء المثلج لمدة طويلة مهما كانت المدة التي تريدها
حتى تصبح باردة عند
لمسها بحيث لا تكون ساخنة بعد الآن ، كما أنها تساعد
على تلوين الكثير من الخضروات.
سيبدو أكثر إشراقًا ، وهو الكثير من
الأعشاب اللطيفة التي تعتبر عنصرًا أساسيًا ولكن تشتهر
بفترة صلاحية قصيرة
إذا وضعت طريقة التبييض والصدمة
في الاختبار ، فقد
تعيد بعضًا منها
ولكن إذا اتخذت خطوة واحدة  علاوة على ذلك ،
امزج مع الزيت ، سيظهر خليط أخضر حيوي
سلالة لمدة 30 دقيقة ، وقد حصلت
على زيت منقوع
يمكن استخدامه بعدد من
الطرق اللذيذة ،
تعد الثلاجة خيارًا رائعًا لتخزين
هذا الزيت متعدد الاستخدامات ولكن يمكن أن
يطيل الفريزر  الحياة أكثر من ذلك ، لا يمكنك
استخدام الأعشاب المجمدة كما تريد
الأعشاب الطازجة ، لذا فأنت تقوم بتجميد الزيت
، وبعد ذلك يمكنك نوعًا ما أن تأخذ
مكعب الثلج هذا أو أعتقد أن مكعب الزيت
يخرج من الفريزر ثم يوضع في مقلاة
وبعد ذلك سيساعد ذلك g  أضف
نكهة طبقك مع الزيت الذي يحمي الأعشاب
[الموسيقى]
علم المطبخ له حدوده
ولا يمكنك حفظها جميعًا ، لذا استخدم الفطرة
السليمة وأنفك إذا كانت رائحتها
سيئة فمن المحتمل أن
الطعام سيتحلل في نهاية المطاف يومًا ما
ولكن إذا تمكنا من استخدامه
لشيء آخر يكون أجنبيًا أفضل